okay I'm excited Pat I am very excited
last week we announced a membership
contest sponson sponsored by Patrick
Ferreira and the idea was it is an
audio-visual contest we've had
membership giveaways in the past where
the applicants or participants I guess
is the right way to refer to them have
to write something a progressive
patriotic letter for example or it was
open to college students who had to
write in a short essay about what the
david pakman show means to them whatever
I liked the gr inspired incoherent rant
contest incoherent rant contest
sponsored by GR whatever this time
Patrick Ferreira wanted an Instagram
based audio-visual contest where there
were five memberships available for
people who created some kind of
audio-visual material related in some
way to the show and I am ready to
present the five winners to you okay
first and foremost is this one that
you're seeing here which we'll put up
for full screen for you this is a
caricature of me done by Haven Herrera
and I have to tell you this is a pretty
good caricature I've had other
caricatures done that don't really they
just don't really look like me this one
does the nose shape perfectly what's
known as the Triceratops nose in some
circles of my family the eyebrows are
pretty solid the eyes a little too close
together are pretty good the sort of
hairstyle is good I think my chin is not
nearly this big but but that's okay this
is a really good caricature really good
I like the colors I like the Boston
skyline in the back oh yeah that's the
dental center in those backgrounds and
nice subtleties there I only just
noticed that that's the Prudential and
in the lower left you actually see that
see the Zakim bridge I did not even
notice that so this is excellent Haven
you've got a year david pakman show
membership for free courtesy of Patrick
Ferrara next this is Instagrammer see
top kiss see top kiss you speculated Pat
that if there were any cartoon if
occations done of you they would be
unflattering right and see top kiss did
what he considers a very flattering
caricature ization of you I have to tell
you this is pretty good I think it's
flattering as well I'm talking about it
and what I love is that this came
from the announcement video from this
contest right and I was pointing to the
caricature of you in the background and
little did I know at that time that that
would become a caricature of me yeah
it's uh it's its inception like no doubt
about it see top kiss congratulations
you've earned a year david pakman show
membership next is a video this is from
Instagram er Brian V Connor
Brian V Connor did a little remix of
what if I wasn't Jewish take a look at
this this is what would be different if
I weren't Jewish what's so horrible
about being a Nazi short and sweet
short and sweet of course those if you
were listening we're two completely
unrelated videos in the second one I'm
actually quoting someone else that must
have taken a lot of work though I mean
those are old videos to track down those
videos yeah so very clever of Brian V
Connor you have won a membership next is
Elliott B 776 this is a really funny
mashup of Kyle kolinsky from secular
talk with hit the face has been
photoshopped to be my face even though
it's Kyle : skis body Kyle kolinsky
studio Kyle : skis attire and a pat is
also on one of Kyle : skis screen
because why not says ye zip zip zip 'ti
which i think is something Kyle says
right now - Kyle ISM I think he does and
he kind of like holds his blazer the way
that he's doing in this image so very
very clever putting my face on Kyle :
skis body that is the fourth winner of
the free membership and lastly Eitan
grad that's the username has done a
drawing which is a complete mash-up of a
million different references from the
show you've got our logo it's a map of
Texas where former producer Lewis used
to live it's a map of New England it has
a calendar which says the date is August
17th 2005 the at the date of the first
was at 17th or 23rd anyway August of
2005 when the show started there is a
Boston College flag I am of course
teaching at Boston College there is a
little poster that is visit tel-aviv
which I did there's a David Pakman show
coffee mug an Argentine flag there's a
Kerik a Carrick referencing of course
Pat's Keurig scandals of the last year
and
there's some other items that I don't
totally know the references to I think
it's a paint bucket and a piece of cake
and some scale there justice yeah really
really good
okay so Eitan also a good one five
winners free memberships get in touch we
need you to get in touch because since
this was through Instagram I actually
don't have people's email addresses to
set up your free memberships